um i  think rogervo just missed a win sorry uh  let's see what happened there  so in the current position it looks like  it's about to be a draw black's three  points up but this position  just bishop h2  apparently and rook f7 next  wow  wins  a piece i think  is it  i mean how do you stop rook f7 and rook  c7 check  key seven rook f8 check wins  also bishop h2 was win  uh i mean i was taught by our producer  yeah um white was winning and i guess  this is it because in the game it's  about to be a draw  wow well he went down to one minute  and there's literally i mean literally  nothing else to do you lose the pieces  black you might have a couple of pawns  but it's not i know he didn't have one  minute he had more  yeah  four minutes he had four minutes but how  is it possible that he just went through  kf7 and then he went for this  i think he just trusted rapport right he  trusted his opponent